Một tháng bày toán hướng phát thái lan đình chỉ chức vộ của tụi tuấn về trong thân sinh nào qua chè.
Sau khi bà có cuộc đệ đạp bị giòn gì, bơi chủ tịch thử vệnh các mù trường hôn xem,
dây bên hệ mở đau một gia đoạn chính trị nhiều bến đậu với thái lan.
Chúng khi đó, bà về tụi thăm tham thử như quên lĩnh đạo cho có tụi tuấn Sharia,
trong vùng vô khí.
Sự điều giễn xa giữa lúc phái lan đang chữ sức cách từ tình khi mình dơi với các mù tría,
bà quá trình đang phán thế quan với Mỹ.
Trong kịch bà bất lời, đang vưu thái giữa bà về trong thân giận sất,
có thể phải cháo lại vài cho thủ tuấn cho lãnh đạo đảng tự hà thái lan,
an utin cho viên rà côn.
Giờ tập sinh nào qua chè với bà đời thủ tuấn,
này đăng đối diện thủ thách lớn,
khi cảo thặc sinh và bà dinh lắc đều bướng giác dối pháp lĩ,
có bà phía trong thân dơi và bất lời dấu thiệu kinh nghiệm chính trị.
Giòn gì để đam khiến kinh tên tiếp theo trong giống hòa sinh nào qua chè,
giống hòa ở từng đường xem là biểu tự dân tối của chính trường thái lan,
tiếp tục vướng vào bà bói.
Chúng tôi cạnh các của biểu tình và đồ tài sĩnh,
chính phù dân nhà sinh nào qua chè nắm quyền,
tiếp tục phai đối mặt với khu hoàn,
chia sẻ và tương hoàn đầy bà đồn.